la vérité est que le monde riche parle beaucoup
et récemment
est je pense un mauvais compte et
tort je suis luiz inácio lula da
Silva l'ancien président de la république de
Brésil
Je suis détenu ici à la police fédérale
571 jours
bien
le fait le plus pauvre qui affecte le
l'université est solitaire et que je
Je vis avec très peu de gens que j'essaye
essayez de survivre en lisant votre
le temps de survivre
avoir un lecteur flash regarder la discussion
politique
voir l'analyse de diverses conjonctures
être des films
Je regarde beaucoup ce qui se passe dans le
congrès national qui a lieu en pt
ce qui se passe dans le court congrès fito
connaître l'implication
J'essaie de remplir ma journée sans
laisser l'huile laisser le
la colère prend le dessus sur ma vie parce que je
Je veux sortir d'ici fort
je peux dire que je lis plus ici
qu'aujourd'hui est propre que le mouvement de
ma vie parce que la lecture remplit un
une partie de mon temps libre et puis c'est
c'est bien que tu lis je suis désolé je n'ai pas lu
tant de contrôle aujourd'hui il y a 50 ans et
ledit seigneur a appris de tous ces
livres quelle était la chose la plus importante
que tu étais le plus
chose importante que j'ai apprise est de prendre soin de
votre équilibre clé tandis que le fémur
humain de ne rien permettre qui
ne pas être utile peut prendre soin de la vôtre
le sommeil peut prendre soin de votre aube
tu sais donc j'essaie d'être toujours tu sais
à jour avec mon âme avec mon cœur
ma tête et ça me fait du bien et j'ai dit
je suis l'homme croyant j'ai créé un dieu
Tu sais
Je pense que je pense que fidel est ce que je
J'imagine que l'amour est fini Lisa je sais
Je pense que je suis ici pour accomplir cela
demander cette sanction injuste
c'est cette crapule qui m'a arrêté
avoir une approbation de Dieu et donc je
Je vais accomplir mon rituel ici en sachant
que celui qui a fait ça a tort et qui a été
vu un jour devra être puni
c'est ce qui me garde fort pour
volonté de se battre avec volonté de se battre
combat tu sais et en espérant que le Brésil
améliorez-le en votant un peu
eu ici est je voudrais savoir ce que
vous manquez le plus depuis le
monsieur entra au siège de
direction de la police fédérale
Les gens pour qui je ne suis pas allé me ​​manquent
manque de bébé pas toujours manque de nourriture
n'importe quoi
les gens me manquent
toute ma vie j'aime vraiment la chura da
relation humaine
j'aime toucher les gens que j'aime
de toucher des gens que tu connais donc je je
non non non devenir esclave d'internet
nouveau, je me suis détourné du câble de téléphone portable parce que je
goûter
tu sais yeux dans les yeux j'aime toucher
car l'être humain et la chimie pure ne font pas
nous sommes un algorithme nous n'avons pas de chimie
pur tu dois savoir si l'humanité est
algorithmes de tournage aujourd'hui, c'est-à-dire
le trafic est capable de savoir tout ce que vous
pense à la vie est capable de diriger votre
voter
assis du faux mille de la part de
l'industrie du mensonge donc je veux
rester un politicien conservateur
nombres habitude de préférer la relation
l'homme sait en regardant les gens voir le
brésil attraper des gens au brésil
Je suis comme ça et j'espère voir si jusqu'au
le deuil et l'hotel dernier jour de ma vie
président en août de la même année étaient
plus de 30 000 foyers de
les incendies en Amazonie ont presque triplé
l'année dernière, j'aimerais savoir si dans
votre avis protéger l'amazone est un
à la charge de
voir mais pas l'esprit évident que le
amazon est un territoire national donc
fait partie de la responsabilité du Brésil
prends soin de l'amazone
cela ne signifie pas que le Brésil peut
se passer de l'aide internationale
moi-même quand j'étais président participe
de la signature de la création d'un fonds en
auquel l'allemagne et la norvège ont participé
fonds international d'aide aux soins
explorer la biodiversité pour prendre soin de la
Écosystème amazonien
le président français c'est une cruelle
dit qu'il n'excluait pas l'idée de
créer un statut international pour
amazon que pensez-vous que je
Je pense qu'un quota est faux et malavisé
un compte dans une partie d'Amazon qui est
Guyane française et pourrait prendre bien soin
de la ligue avec beaucoup d'affection avec beaucoup
sois prudent et si tu veux aider le Brésil je pense
que le Brésil doit accepter tout
aide parce que la région amazonienne est une
région très étendue y a autour
plus de 22 millions d'êtres humains et
qui ont besoin de qualité de vie
donc pour développer
si nous pouvons faire le
amazon à développer avec grand soin
un soin particulier pour l'environnement
prendre soin de notre forêt de nos
la faune de notre rivière s'enfuit moins à pied
le mieux et cinq c'est de l'argent pour
aider sans l'intrusion de la volonté et
l'envoyer à l'amazone je pense que c'est une bonne chose
la politique et le brésil devraient en profiter
connaître tous les alliés qui veulent contribuer
mais tu comprends que certains
Les dirigeants occidentaux s'inquiètent
l'avenir de l'époque amazonienne je pense que le
Amazon et je pense que l'océan tout ça
avoir une collaboration aujourd'hui et le
engagement d'entraide de tous
présidents du monde
la vérité est que le monde riche parle beaucoup
et parle peu parce que je sais que je suis allé
à la rencontre de copenhague en 2009
à ce jour, les États n'ont pas été inculpés
unis l'accord que
un autre à ce jour, les Américains ne le font pas
à l'écoute et à la réunion de copenhague
l'union européenne voulait s'éloigner du
protocole de Kyoto et voulait blâmer
La Chine sur la question de la pollution
planète
maintenant je sais que le
Les Américains veulent sortir de l'affaire
Paris
donc en fait tu dois prendre en compte
compte que beaucoup de choses qui
les pays riches discutent pour s'occuper de
l'environnement dans la vérité et le respect de
les pauvres, c'est-à-dire les pauvres
l'Afrique en développement ne veut pas continuer
être éternel connaît la zone vide de de
industrie du développement de l'emploi
tout le monde veut développer ce qui est
ce qu'il faut, c'est que les pays riches aident les
les pays les plus pauvres en finançant
développement de ce pays et contribuer à
prendre soin de la préservation de l'environnement
lorsque l'interlocuteur est le Brésil
à Rio de Janeiro
c'était une réunion pour discuter de la moitié
environnement dont il n'avait pas pris possession
france il voit ici j'ai dit président
social me permet de donner des conseils
je donnerai éventuellement des conseils
n'oubliez pas de mettre le discours que
vous a fait élire à la tête du
ton lit et tous les jours quand tu te lèves lis
quel a été le discours qui l'a élu
président pour que vous n'oubliiez jamais
parce que la tentative est la presse et
l'opposition les a forcés est de changer le discours
et quand on change on perd
la confiance de la société et c'est ce que
c'est arrivé en france
J'aimerais savoir à quoi tu penses
du président américain Donald Trump
[Chanson]
sais qu'il est difficile pour toi de porter un jugement
de personnes que vous ne connaissez pas
Je pense que les États-Unis sont un pays
très important, je pense que le Brésil a
d'avoir une relation démocratique et
civilisé avec le dicton dessus
moi seulement dans le mâle que le brésil devrait être
servile
Le Brésil doit se battre pour être un
grande puissance et ne pas être un
petit pays admirant les etats unis
sans vouloir grandir sans estime de soi alors
Honnêtement, je ne pense pas que l'atout
est bon pour la démocratie parce que parce que
il n'agit pas du tout démocratiquement
le président du plus grand pays du monde qui
gouverner le pays via twitter
ce n'est pas possible d'aller à droite ce n'est pas possible
réussir
w essayer après 60 ans si
abattre le mur de Berlin qu'il veut
construire un mur entre le mexique et le
les états unis ne sont pas une séparation
idéologique n'est pas la guerre froide c'est une
guerre contre les pauvres une guerre
contre les pauvres c'est ça donc cet homme
n'a pas de coeur cet homme n'a pas
non non ce n'est pas démocratique que le film
il n'y a aucune raison de savoir mériter le respect
juste à l'esprit qui est un démocrate ne peut pas
pense que cet homme est bon
il n'est pas du genre à accueillir et s'il en a
chose positive que rien n'a fait dans le
vivre là-bas je ne peux pas juger le président de
un autre pays je peux je le voudrais
respecte moi au moins les enfants de
l'amérique latine des pays des caraïbes qui
par temps de pauvreté chercher la chance en nous
États-Unis
sachez que cet enfant n'était pas
des entreprises comme lui essaient de faire chaque jour le
pourriez-vous citer quelque chose
positif que jair bolsonaro a fait
depuis le début de son mandat
regarde c'est très difficile c'est très difficile moi
je te donne cette interview
après avoir vu une déposition
l'intempérant du président est en Arabie
Une Saoudienne à propos de son problème de gardien
sur le problème de la mort de marielly
heheheheh j'ai vu cette vidéo hier
qu'il a fait
connaître le lion entourant vienne est une chose
pathétique pour le président de la république
qui devrait s'inquiéter 210
millions de personnes qui vendraient devraient
s'occuper de générer des millions de
emplois dans ce pays parce que le travail qui
de la citoyenneté aux personnes
travailler et gagner un bon salaire
faut se soucier de la qualité
de la vie dans ce pays connaît cependant
le président fait son show
pour les miliciens il si bien
représente qu'il a besoin de savoir sait que
toutes les bêtises dont il était vaillant
felipe president maintenant avec le president
il doit régner pour 210 millions
habitants les gens veulent travailler
envie de manger
Je veux étudier, je veux vivre heureux et je veux
vivre en paix et il ne se sert pas
et pour toi quelle était la pire chose
ce qu'il a fait jusqu'à aujourd'hui
Je pense que le pire qui défend jusqu'à aujourd'hui
il a commencé par la question du plus
médecins et il a renvoyé les médecins
Cubains qui travaillaient plus dur
médecins, qui est de mettre l'objectif un
place et à ce jour vous avez des milliers de
villes qui n'ont pas de médecins, ma petite-fille était une
l'une des choses les plus sérieuses qu'il ait faites dans un
démonstration d'irresponsabilité
la santé des gens
la deuxième chose qu'il fait
c'est la réforme des retraites et la
réforme du travail en fait, il est
introduire dans le pays le retour du travail
esclave dans lequel le travailleur va
travaille et n'a pas de journée de travail
n'a pas de document enregistré il n'a pas
droit aux soins médicaux à partir de maintenant
peu il n'a pas le droit de
retraite
En d'autres termes, c'est le Brésil qui remonte au XIXe siècle
c'est ce que je pense que les choses étaient
sérieux à honorer ou quelque chose de plus sérieux que
est en train de faire est le combat dit
tempéré avec les pays d'Amérique du Nord
sud et la tentative de privatiser
Entreprises publiques brésiliennes
à votre avis le président officiel
réussi à comprendre les difficultés et
besoins du peuple brésilien
il ne pourrait jamais comprendre
le besoin des gens ne lit même jamais
soucieux de discuter de la nécessité
peuple brésilien
Il est important de connaître la vie passée du
fonctionnaire était un lieutenant du
armée qui s'est battue avec un vieil homme si
a pris sa retraite comme capitaine très tôt et
De là, il a été élu conseiller de
des clubs militaires de Rio de
Janvier
puis il a été élu conseiller a été élu
sept fois adjoint pour te battre
s'inquiéter et ne jamais s'inquiéter sinon
connaît le discours d'un employé
parler des problèmes des gens
ou vous avez son discours taquiner
quelqu'un je vais avoir un discours de sa part
parler dans un discours botanique violent
de lui défendant le milicien alors ce
l'homme a accédé à la présidence de la république
à cause de l'huile qui s'est répandue
dans ce pays à partir de 2003 sur de la merde
mieux après la victoire de dilma de
donc ce citoyen a été élu président
par le déni de la politique et ça ne marche pas
nulle part au monde sauf le
seigneur pense que les changements deviennent émotionnels
fait maintenant sont irréversibles
voir je pense qu'ils l'auront effectué
donner avec le nouveau gouvernement
pourquoi vous ou vous changez pour le mieux
ou vous aurez le peuple brésilien dans
Le peuple chilien est dans la même situation aujourd'hui
ce qui se passe au chili
ce qui arrive au retraité en
le chili c'est ce qui va se passer au brésil
est encore très grand et quel pays est né
être un protagoniste international
problème est que l'élite brésilienne qui
gouverne ce pays a toujours été de servir
sauvé était serviteur de la couronne portugaise
pour avoir l'apparence de la couronne anglaise et est
serviteur des états-unis et seigneur
penser à postuler en 2022
alors ce n'est pas une décision personnelle
descente le fils constance jusqu'à la fin dans le
temps
qui ont des circonstances conflictuelles
vous obliger à faire ce geste
Je suis prêt à faire n'importe quel geste
mais je pense que pt connaît une fête très
grand sur la gauche se développe dans le
Le Brésil, je pense, a beaucoup de noms pour
être candidat à quelque chose que je ne connais même pas
en interne, je n'ai pas besoin d'être candidat pour
président vous avez dû le voir avec
sûr que les récentes manifestations dans le
chili contre les violences policières et
inégalité sociale
ainsi que le retour du péronisme en
l'argentine ni les élections en uruguay
donc on en regarde un nouveau
c'est un nouveau souffle de gauche en amérique
latina mais nous avons parfois le
l'impression que ce mouvement est toujours
très faible au brésil comme toi
Expliquez cela et parlons d'un nouveau souffle
de la gauche dira encore une chose
large qui est un nouveau souffle de démocratie
ça se passe dans notre cher
Amérique latine
Je vais dire une chose que je devrais
quand il était président
la démocratie n'est pas un pacte de
le silence
La démocratie est une société en évolution
se battre pour plus de conquêtes et essayer
conquérir à travers vos luttes
ce que nous disons, c'est la société
découvrant que ceux qui vendaient le
le néolibéralisme comme sortie de crise
parce que chaque fois que quelqu'un de néolibéral
veut résoudre le problème de la crise, il
la crise s'aggrave en plus
les travailleurs c'est plus le chômage c'est moins
le salaire est moins de revenu, c'est-à-dire, et les gens
commencé à s'élever contre ça non
ne doute pas qu'ici au Brésil, les gens
augmentera également à un moment donné
pourriez-vous envoyer un message
directement le look de la jeunesse brésilienne
si vous êtes découragé
si vous ne croyez pas et aucun politicien
si vous ne croyez pas au calmar si vous ne le faites pas
crois la vérité si tu ne le fais pas
dans le bon employé si vous ne croyez pas
sabino fils si tu ne crois pas en non
gâteau si vous marquez toujours la terre de la marina
alors ne vous découragez pas car le bon politicien
que vous rêvez qui sait n'est pas et
aucun de nous n'est en toi
donc au lieu de nier la politique
assumer sa responsabilité que le
Le Brésil est à toi et que tu aideras
faire en sorte que ce pays redevienne un
pays qui nous a rendus fiers et qui a été
passe et vous avez le courage de
se battre pour avoir le courage de se plaindre est plus facile que
ce qui est important dans pour luca, c'est lequel
sont vos plans personnels pour quand
alors laisse juste le premier que je veux
vivre jusqu'à 120 ans
Je pense que le sens a déjà tout dit
jour que l'homme qui vivra 120 ans
est né donc je continue à me demander pourquoi
ce n'est pas moi donc le livre est une raison de
qui est le bruit d'avoir le second est que
à 74 ans je suis amoureux
à travers alors vous voulez une plus grande raison de
vivre qu'un citoyen passionné
cependant vivre pour en profiter
passion depuis au moins 30 ans
donc je joue beaucoup après tory a
la mort qui ne cherche pas à m'approcher
parce qu'ici elle en trouvera un
barrière très dure
elle va devoir prendre beaucoup de monde va moi
faire avant de me prendre parce que j'aime
de la vie sait et je pense après cela
l'approbation que je suis ici je pense
Dieu sera plus généreux avec moi et
dit lia rester un peu plus longtemps là-bas
[Chanson]